it's no ordinary frontline these men
aren't soldiers and their rounds are
fake but this training footage is real
and it's been posted online the gunmen
are part of a Slovak militia set up as
an information war grips Europe
insignia their leader likes Russia
loathes NATO and thinks Britain lied
about the Solstice by poisoning do you
think maybe that you have been
manipulated so you have been reading
Russian disinformation and that has made
you think the way you do innocence with
this parameter I am
a car you take it as possible knock a
bloke at see many more dos Campos
competitors so those would be
knuckleheads bully experiment here
others disagree this expert accuses
Moscow of using fake news to divide the
EU and boost support for the far-right
but some political parties appear to be
exploiting the same disinformation tools
people saw this as a very easy way how
to score political points and they see
that this type of narratives bashing the
you bashing NATO bashing us could win
potentially political points it's not
only one side doing the bashing in a
battle of the keyboards Britain is
providing support for experts here in
Bratislava and across Europe to counter
Russian disinformation it's an important
goal but as anyone listening this EU
Roadshow illustrates Slovakia's lack of
interest in the European Parliament
polls disenfranchised voters ensured the
lowest turnout of any EU country last
election
it makes this low-income state
particularly vulnerable to
disinformation amplifying populist
voices promising change enter the party
of slovakia's far-right they're riding
high in the polls so it's perhaps no
coincidence they're championed by sites
accused of fake news but there's also
genuine support for the party despite
claims of fascist links
the fight against this information isn't
the only game in town
Russian fans are making themselves heard
at the world ice hockey championship
they pose no threat but suspicions
remain about their government defeat for
Britain and its allies in this
information war would give Russia much
more to celebrate
Deborah Haynes Sky News Bratislava